one of the best morning routines I can
recommend to any person on earth is that
you wake up and you decrease the time
between when you wake up and when you
start working we have a bunch of buddies
Mutual that have exited companies for
hundreds of millions of dollars and then
they get like really obsessed with their
health and they have these massive
morning routines and they just get upset
you know all these supplements and red
lights on us everyone who's watching
says oh this person's successful this is
what they do I should do that but what
got them there is not what they're doing
now now right right so it's like you
want to model the rise and so a lot of
times the rise is a lot of imbalance
they're Absolut trade-offs and it's just
whether or not you're willing to pay the
price for it if the Nikes that you want
on the wall are $500 that is the price
you can just choose to pay it or not but
if you choose to pay the $500 for the
Nikes you don't then say this was
unhealthy you just make the trade that's
where a lot of people spend all this
time analyzing themselves like feeling
about their feelings thinking about
their thoughts rather than just
executing